in the last lecture we examined some of
the major misunderstandings associated
with the vietnam war
but vietnam is far from the only
american war that is misunderstood
indeed numerous misunderstandings exist
about most american wars
so do numerous myths one major myth
concerns our tradition of
citizen soldiers to fight our wars a
tradition
that began in the colonial era with
every able-bodied male
supposedly ready to grab his trusty
musket off the mantel piece of his home
and go out to successfully defend his
community
be it against indians or the french
or the spanish or during the
revolutionary war
against the british now as with most
myths
this one contains an element of truth
indeed
much more than simply an element
during the 17th century colonists had to
rely upon themselves for defense
and they thus created in the new world
from english tradition
the militia system in which every
able-bodied adult male
in the community was a member and liable
for military training on muster days as
well as military service
when called up militia were heavily
involved in the revolutionary war
and the militia system was enshrined in
federal law
after the revolutionary war with the
militia act of 1792
that remained the basic military
legislation for the country
until the early 20th century but in
reality
the muster days during the colonial era
were more social events
than occasions for military training and
the militia proved to be
an unreliable as well as an untrained
body of soldiers their members came and
went as they pleased
and their elected or politically
appointed officers were anything but
competent
there were also numerous exemptions from
military service
and the system was in a state of serious
decay
if not outright collapse by the time of
the revolutionary war
now the war did witness a major revival
of the militia system
but its members for the most part
remained unreliable
and unable to stand up to british
regulars
especially a british bayonet charge
washington consequently placed little
faith
in the militia and instead focused
during the war on the creation and the
rigorous training
of his continental army to fight the
british
regulars militia did play a crucial role
in numerous battles
and in winning the war but only when
properly led
and primarily in conjunction with the
continental
army had washington been able to have
his way
little reliance would have been placed
on militia after the war
but realizing that would be politically
impossible
as well as ideologically and practically
impossible
washington called for a system whereby
the central government would control the
militia
and impose uniformity on it in terms of
arms
organization and training but that
proved to be equally
impossible consequently a dual defense
system
emerged under the constitution it
consisted of a small
professional army and the state
militia with authority over state
militia
split between the national and state
governments
but with the passage of the militia act
of 1792
what that actually translated into was
no centralized control
and no uniformity all males aged 18 to
45
were required by this act to enroll in
the militia
but there was no federal control over
training arms or
officer selection primary reliance was
thus
placed not on the militia but on a small
professional army
augmented by volunteers in times of war
as well as a draft during the civil war
and
on special elite volunteer
militia units that had begun to form in
the colonial era
these gradually evolved during the late
19th century
into the present-day national guard
now militia units were used during the
19th century
usually with disappointing results they
did very poorly during the war of 1812
and they their lawless behavior during
the war with mexico
was so outrageous that the mexicans
labeled them quote
bandits vomited from hell regular
officers concurred
and there was little love lost between
militia and the regular army
indeed regular army reformers
consistently called
for either an end to the militia system
or strong
federal control over it
the national guard did come under
greater federal control during the 20th
century
but during the two world wars and the
cold war primary reliance for manpower
was placed upon a national draft a
system of
universal military training was proposed
but it never passed consequently we
retain today
the dual system of a regular army and
elite volunteer militia units but that
is not the citizen soldier concept of
universal military obligation and
service
that as well as the belief that
untrained
or poorly trained citizens can defeat
regulars
is part of our national mythology
another major myth is that we and our
leaders only go to war for defensive
reasons
and when forced by aggressors to do so
in this regard
many view the decision by president
george w
bush to go to war against iraq in 2003
as an anomaly a break from past american
history and
traditions it is not
the fact that we went to war in iraq on
the basis of faulty or manipulated
intelligence regarding
weapons of mass destruction is also
viewed incorrectly
as an anomaly in american history in
reality
numerous past presidents have presented
incorrect
information sometimes knowingly
sometimes
unknowingly in order to obtain
congressional
and public approval of war
similarly incorrect is the belief that
we americans always quote win the war
but lose the peace
because of our political naivete in
point of fact
the reverse has often been the case the
rest of this lecture
will attempt to dispel such myths by
examining presidential behavior
prior to america's major wars as well as
the
military history of those wars and the
political
results let's look first at the issue of
defensive wars
versus wars by choice historically
many if not most of our wars have been
wars by choice
important fact only world war one and
world war ii were wars in which we were
actually
forced to declare war by the previous
actions of our enemies
in the 19th century both the 1846 to 48
war with mexico
and the 1898 war with spain were wars by
choice
the first to acquire california and new
mexico
as well as a favorable boundary for
texas and the second to force the
spanish out of cuba
similarly in the 20th century we chose
to go to war in korea
and in vietnam in the 1960s as part of
the cold war
in a somewhat gray area is the war of
1812
as president madison and the congress
went to war in desperation
because of the failure of their previous
measures
of economic coercion designed to force
the british
to cease violating american neutral
rights on the high
seas well what about the civil war
the south chose to secede and to fight
for independence
while the north chose war in order to
prevent this
similarly americans chose to fight
against what they saw
as british violations of their rights in
1775
while britain chose to crush their
rebellion by force
even in the two world wars our enemies
argued
that our previous non-neutral acts had
made us
an unofficial belligerent and forced
them to attack us
in 1917 it was our booming trade in war
material
and our loans to the allied powers that
led the germans to announce unrestricted
submarine warfare
against our shipping as well as
everybody else's
in 1941 it was our freezing of japanese
assets
which in effect embargoed the oil and
steel
that japan relied upon and that is what
led tokyo
to try to obtain these resources by
force in southeast asia
and to attack the only military force
capable of stopping them the us fleet at
pearl harbor
similarly the decision via the lend
lease act of 1941
to give war material free of charge
first to britain
and eventually to the soviet union and
then to use the u.s navy to help convoy
that war material across the atlantic
made the united states an unofficial
belligerent
in the war against germany
in all of these wars we argued that our
enemies left us
no choice but to go to war but because
we
made such a claim does not mean that it
was true
well what about incorrect and or
manipulated evidence for going to war
in 1846 president james k
polk manipulated both the evidence and
the way it was presented
so as to leave the congress with no
choice saved to declare war
first he sent an army under general
zachary taylor
into disputed territory along the rio
grande river
and when taylor's army clashed with the
mexican army
polk asked congress for war on the
grounds that quote american blood had
been shed upon
american soil but it was disputed soil
not american soil as a one term
illinois congressman named abraham
lincoln and others would point out
indeed lincoln would get the nickname
spotty for asking pogue to identify the
spot
on which american blood had been shed
upon american soil
in addition to this polk may very well
have sent taylor's
army into the disputed territory to
provoke a war
as he was determined to obtain
california and his efforts to do so
by diplomatic negotiation had failed
now in addition to all this
congressional democrats
attached the war resolution as a rider
to a military appropriations bill for
the army
and a portion of that army was then
engaged in hostilities
that made it nearly impossible to vote
against the measure
jumping to world war ii in september of
1941
president franklin d roosevelt claimed
that the u.s destroyer greer had been
quote wantonly attacked by a german
submarine
in the atlantic and he responded as
commander-in-chief
with an order for u.s warships to shoot
on-site
when they spotted german submarines that
began
an undeclared naval war with nazi
germany
one that became official when hitler
declared war on the united states
soon after pearl harbor
but in reality the greer had been
trailing the german submarine
and radioing its position back to a
british fleet
that had responded with air attacks
against the sub
the submarine had fired on the grier in
self-defense
now more common historically than such
blatant manipulation of the facts
has been the presentation of evidence
that was believed
at the time but that later research
showed to be incorrect one of the major
factors the president james madison
cited
in asking congress for a declaration of
war
in june of 1812 with a british orders
and council
that madison claimed violated american
neutral rights actually
those orders in council had already been
rescinded
but neither madison nor the congress
knew that in june of 1812
because the news could not travel to
america
that rapidly the only way was sailing
ship
and it arrived the news arrived after
war had already been declared
in 1898 one of the major reasons
congress declared war on spain
was the sinking of the u.s battleship
maine in havana harbor
a sinking that two navy boards of
inquiry concluded had been caused by an
external mine
and that the public believed obviously
had been planted there by the spanish
but no evidence was ever presented that
the spanish had been responsible for the
mine
and in the 1970s a detailed navy study
concluded that the previous boards of
inquiry had been
incorrect and that in all likelihood the
main had been destroyed by
an internal explosion caused by
spontaneous combustion in a coal bunker
that then ignited a powder magazine
and blew up the entire ship
in a separate category are war causing
events
that were believed at the time because
the administration
wanted to believe them and consequently
ignored contrary evidence
in august of 1964 president lyndon
johnson
and defense secretary robert mcnamara
claimed that
two attacks had taken place against
american destroyers in the gulf of
tonkin
by north vietnamese torpedo boats
they did this in order to obtain passage
of the tonkin gulf resolution
authorizing the president to use force
to prevent
future attacks johnson would later use
that resolution
to justify his ensuing americanization
of the vietnam war that had not been his
aim in august of 1964.
rather his aim had been to send a
message to north vietnam
regarding american unity and seriousness
of purpose
and as i previously noted to neutralize
the issue of vietnam
in the 1964 presidential election
campaign
for those reasons the administration had
prepared
this resolution months earlier and was
simply waiting for an
episode to justify presenting it
it thus chose to ignore contrary
evidence arriving
that the second attack may never have
taken place
the first attack clearly did but that
the second attack had never
taken place that the blips on u.s
sonar were actually caused by the wakes
of the ships as they took evasive action
that was not needed second supposed
attack
took place at night the administration
also chose to ignore its own actions
that had probably
led to the first attack in particular
de soto intelligence gathering missions
with warships running into north
vietnamese territorial waters
and then racing out and oplan 34a
operations against the north vietnamese
coast
by south vietnamese commandos who were
transported
in american naval vessels
similarly the bush administration nearly
40 years later
relied on faulty intelligence to claim
that saddam hussein
possessed weapons of mass destruction
and it ignored contrary evidence
in all likelihood because it had already
decided to go to war
and had convinced itself that the iraqi
dictator
did possess such weapons
what about the cliche that the united
states always wins the wars and loses
the peace
historically the reverse has been the
case more often
militarily the united states did not win
the war of 1812
and politically it did not lose the
peace to the contrary
its military forces were consistently
defeated by the british
in 1812 and in 1813
and in 1814 the british invaded and
burned
washington only the last minute turning
back of a british assault on baltimore
and the turning back of a british
invasion down the champlain valley
at the battle of plattsburgh bay
prevented total defeat
yet american diplomats at ghent in
belgium
proved superior to british diplomats and
obtained a
highly favorable peace treaty one that
ended
previous british talk of obtaining
american territory in the war
and creating a separate indian nation to
block
further american expansion the peace
treaty
also implicitly accepted american
sovereignty
much more strongly than had the peace
treaty of 1783
that ended the revolutionary war
as for the neutral rights issues that
had led the united states into a
declaration of war
they were rendered immaterial because of
the simultaneous
end of the napoleonic wars
what about the war with mexico 1846-48
here we won both the war and the peace
at least the peace president polk had
wanted
when the war started but as the war went
on
poke and many americans thought more and
more
about acquiring all of mexico just
annexing
the entire country polk then
accepted a more limited treaty
that obtained his original territorial
desires
california new mexico the rio grande
boundary
one reason he did so and indeed
one reason his peace envoy nicholas
trist
disobeyed orders polk had ordered him
home trist disobeyed those orders
and negotiated this peace treaty why
because despite its military victories
the small army in mexico city faced the
risk
of being cut off and having to deal with
guerrilla warfare
the head of that army general winfield
scott
asked trist to stay and to sign the
peace treaty
what about the 1898 war with spain
here we also won the war and the peace
indeed we acquired an overseas empire
that territorially went beyond
what we had actually conquered during
the war
as for world war one contrary to popular
belief
while the united states did play an
important role in the eventual allied
victory
its participation in the war was brief
officially less than two years in
reality less than one
on the actual battlefields and the
united states was not
primarily responsible for the allied
victory
indeed the initial collapse of the
german army and the central powers as a
whole
took place in areas far removed
from american forces
yet the very limited role played by
those forces
was sufficient to enable president
woodrow wilson
to claim a dominant role at the paris
peace conference
indeed his only very firm instruction
to general john j pershing was to keep
the american army separate
not to allow it to be amalgamated into
french and british forces
so that he would have a strong
bargaining position
at the paris peace conference now wilson
did not get everything he wanted
at paris but the compromises in the
treaty of versailles
reflected most of what he wanted
most notably the league of nations that
the league
failed to keep the peace is not relevant
that is a separate issue
similarly and as discussed in a previous
lecture
the united states did not win world war
ii
all by itself it provided only 25
of the allied armed forces during that
war
nor did it lose the peace first of all
there never was a peace to lose
as the cold war precluded the
negotiation of any peace treaty
or even the calling of a peace
conference
as for the claim that we nevertheless
lost the peace to joseph stalin
during the wartime yalta conference a
conference in which a supposedly naive
roosevelt
gave away half of the world to stalin
that
very statement incorrectly assumes
that roosevelt possessed that half of
the world to give away
as previously explained he did not
furthermore despite its limited
contribution to military victory
the united states emerged from world war
ii
as by far the most powerful nation in
the world
and indeed the most powerful nation the
world has ever seen
british historian ajp taylor once
quipped that roosevelt
was the most successful indeed in some
ways the only successful
world war ii leader he made the united
states the greatest power
in the world taylor noted at a cost much
lower than that of any other
major belligerent what about the korean
war
militarily that was a stalemate
nevertheless the united states
did succeed in obtaining its original
political goal
it did not succeed in obtaining the
later one of liberating and unifying all
of korea
but it did succeed in the original goal
the halting of north korean aggression
and the maintenance of the pre-existing
south korea
in vietnam the united states clearly
lost the war
even though it may never have lost the
battle
yet it achieved in the paris peace
accords what nixon and kissinger had
desired
regarding a quote decent interval for
vietnamization
and the removal of american forces from
what had clearly become
a military quagmire
what about the first iraq war here the
united states
succeeded both militarily and
in its stated political goal of halting
iraq's aggression
against kuwait overthrowing saddam
hussein
was not in the original american
or the u.n sanction to go to war
in iraq and of course with the 1991
demise of the soviet union
the united states won the cold war
without ever having defeated a soviet
army
well why then in light of all these
facts do we continue to believe
that we do not start wars that we only
go to war in response to attacks upon us
and on the basis of solid evidence and
that we always win the wars but lose the
peace
to a large extent these myths are the
result of our bitterness
and disappointment regarding the results
of the wars we fought
especially the two world wars
that bitterness and disappointment was
linked to our very
unrealistic expectations regarding the
ability of total military victory
in a coalition war to translate into the
total
recreation of international relations
in the image that we desired and that
president wilson
and president roosevelt enunciated
it didn't it couldn't accomplish that
the two world wars and the nature of
american democracy
also helped to create a mythical belief
that the only
wars worth fighting are total wars
for total victory and a total recreation
of the world
none of that is true the american belief
that it
is led state department official george
kennan
who left the state department and became
a famous
historian led kennen more than 60 years
ago
in a lecture to compare the united
states to a prehistoric dinosaur
with a body the size of a room a large
room
and a brain the size of a pin you
virtually have to whack its tail off
kennen noted
to wake it up and make it aware that its
interests are being threatened
but once awake it responds with such
fury over having been disturbed
and a response that has no limit
that it winds up destroying not only
whoever has
disturbed it but its own habitat
now these myths are also part of our
national mythology about ourselves
that we are a peace-loving people who
only go to war when left with no choice
who are then militarily victorious
against evil enemies
because of our goodness as well as our
military prowess
and divine protection but we are then
foiled and defeated
in the peacemaking because as a
peace-loving people
we are naive about war and peacemaking
this national mythology is in turn based
on a belief
that war is evil and therefore should be
undertaken
only when we are attacked and there is
no choice
that may be true i definitely believe
that it is true on moral grounds
and on practical grounds as well
for war is almost always a great gamble
whose outcome cannot be accurately
predicted but that does not mean
that what we should do avoid war unless
we are attacked and there is no choice
is what we have actually done in our
history
the mythology is also due to the fact
that we tend to confuse
success in battle with success in war
one of the most misnamed books of the
late 20th century was a history of the
german general staff entitled
a genius for war as numerous critics
pointed out
it should have been entitled a genius
for battle as starting and losing two
world wars
does not illustrate a genius for war
a prussian military officer and theorist
carl von klosovitz
knew this and he emphasized in his
classic study on war
almost 200 years ago that wars are
fought
for political goals and make sense only
within that political context
indeed he argued political goals
should to a great extent determine the
military strategy that is used
though so that that strategy does not
inadvertently negate
the very reasons one went to war
war clause of its pointed out has a
tendency
to go to the absolute which was mindless
violence real war was fought for
political goals
but war did have that tendency to the
absolute
unless it was controlled
now our failure to understand this and
to understand the difference between war
and battle
was boldly illustrated after the vietnam
war
by the american who commented to his
vietnamese counterpart that throughout
the war quote
we never lost the battle that may be
correct the vietnamese responded
but it is also irrelevant
george washington came to understand
that during the war for independence
as he achieved the political goal of
independence despite the fact that his
army lost most of its battles and won
very few
but those few as shown in an earlier
lecture
were enough due to their political
consequences
we have forgotten that lesson from our
18th century past
perhaps that is because as our power has
grown
so has our hubris our pride our
arrogance
and our ensuing blindness to our own
[Music]
history
[Music]
you